and you know I was actually thinking
about when I was a kid and I I have a I
have a younger brother and we used to
fight when I was younger because I just
didn't want to listen to him and then
the older I got the more I started to
realize I'm like oh dang it my little
brother's smarter than me and I really
think once as women we just have this
realization guys I think it helps us
when we start to realize hey women in
general were never happy then we can at
least adapt and when we're feeling like
maybe I should leave my marriage my
children and everything I've built
because I saw a soap opera the other day
maybe we'll be like you know what women
were never happy so let's try to be
happy or when we think well I'm smarter
than my husband so I should be in
control maybe we'll step back and think
well maybe he's smarter